♪
>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
HAPPY MONDAY.
IF YOU WATCH DONALD TRUMP
CLOSELY FOUR YEARS IN OFFICE AND
WE DID.
IT BECAME PRETTY CLEAR THE MORE
OUTLAND DISH THE CLAIM THAT
TRUMP HAPPENED TO BE MAKING THE
MORE LIKELY IT WAS TO BE TRUE.
TRUMP DID TEND TO EXAGGERATE AT
TIMES MOSTLY ABOUT TOPICS THAT
DIDN'T MATTER.
HOW BIG IS THE CROWD AT 2016
INAUGURATION?
WHO CARES?
BUT ON THE BIG THINGS, ON
MATTERS OF CIVILIZATION
IMPORTANCE TRUMP TOLD THE TRUTH
BLUNTLY OFTEN WHEN NOBODY ELSE
WOULD.
THE IRAQ WAR WAS A MISTAKE TRUMP
SAID.
ILLEGAL IMMIGRATION IS A
DISASTER.
CHINA IS TAKING OVER THE WORLD.
HAITI IS A PRETTY
DEAFENING HIS TIERIA FOLLOWED
EVERY ONE OF THESE TRUE
STATEMENTS.
AT ONE POINT IN EARLY 2018, CNN
AND "THE WASHINGTON POST" GOT SO
WORKED UP TRYING TO HIDE THE
OBVIOUS, THAT THEY DEVOTED
BLANKET COVERAGE TO THE CLAIM
THAT ACTUALLY IT IS AN AWESOME
AND FULLY FUNCTIONAL COUNTRY.
PERFECT SPOT FOR YOUR NEXT
FAMILY VACATION.
IF YOU DISAGREE WITH THAT,
YOU'RE RACIST.
THAT'S WHAT THEY TOLD US.
THREE YEARS LATER THEY HAVE
DROPPED THE POSE ON HAITI.
LEADERS NOW CONSIDER HAITI SO
AWFUL, THAT JUST BEING FROM
THERE QUALIFIES YOU FOR ASYLUM
IN THE UNITED STATES.
WITH TRUMP GONE, THEY CAN
FINALLY ADMIT THAT.
WHAT WAS ONCE A DANGEROUS
CONSPIRACY THEORY IS A DANGEROUS
SITUATION.
FOR FOUR YEARS NO DANGEROUS
CONSPIRACY THEORY WAS CONSIDERED
MORE DANGEROUS THAN THE CLAIM
THAT HILLARY CLINTON'S
PRESIDENTIAL CAMPAIGN SPIED ON
DONALD TRUMP.
THE VERY IDEA THAT HILLARY
CLINTON, OF ALL PEOPLE, HAD
SPIED ON ANYONE WAS PR
PREPOSTEROUS.
TRUMP WAS EMBOLDENING OUR
ENEMIES.
SO WAS THIS A STUPID OPINION
THAT TRUMP HAD?
IT WAS REALLY A FORM OF TREASON.
AS USUAL, TRUMP KEPT SAYING IT.
WATCH HIM DO IT AGAIN IN ONE OF
HIS LAST SIT DOWN INTERVIEWS AS
PRESIDENT WITH LESLIE STAHL OF
60 MINUTES.
>> THE BIGGEST SCANDAL WAS WHEN
THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
>> THERE'S NO REAL EVIDENCE OF
THAT.
>> OF COURSE THERE IS.
IT'S ALL OVER THE PLACE.
>> NO.
>> LESLIE, THEY SPIED ON MY
CAMPAIGN AND GOT CAUGHT.
>> SIR, CAN I SAY SOMETHING.
THIS IS "60 MINUTES."
WE CAN'T PUT ON THINGS WE CAN'T
VERIFY.
>> YOU WON'T PUT IT ON BECAUSE
IT'S BAD FOR BIDEN.
>> WE CAN'T PUT ON THINGS WE
CAN'T VERIFY.
>> THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
IT'S BEEN TOTALLY VERIFIED.
JUST GO DOWN AND GET THE PAPERS.
THEY SPIED ON MY CAMPAIGN.
THEY GOT CAUGHT.
>> NO.
>> THEN THEY WENT MUCH FURTHER
THAN THAT AND THEY GOT CAUGHT.
YOU WILL SEE THAT, LESLIE.
YOU KNOW THAT, BUT YOU JUST
DON'T WANT TO PUT IT ON THE AIR.
>> NO, AS A MATTER OF FACT, I
DON'T KNOW THAT.
>> Tucker: AS A MATTER OF FACT,
WE CAN'T VERIFY THAT.
THIS IS CBS NEWS.
WE DON'T AIR THINGS WE CAN'T
VERIFY.
REALLY, LESLIE STAHL?
IS THAT TRUE?
WE STILL REMEMBER A CBS NEWS
PIECE THAT CLAIMED DONALD TRUMP
WAS SECRETLY WORKING WITH
VLADAMIR PUTIN.
HOW DID CBS NEWS VERIFY THOSE
FACTS?
AS IT TURNS OUT THAT PARTICULAR
STORY, THE REPORTING, CAME FROM
READING A PIECE WHILE PROBABLY
STANDING IN LINE AT STARBUCKS.
STATELE CLAIMED THAT THE TRUMP
BANK WAS -- HOW DID SLATE.COM
KNOW THIS?
BY CONSULTING A QUOTE, SMALL
TIGHTLY KNIT COMMUNITY OF
COMPUTER SCIENTISTS.
THESE SCIENTISTS WERE TOTALLY
NONPARTISAN.
ONE OF THE SOURCES EXPLAIN WE
WANTED TO DEFEND BOTH CAMPAIGNS
BECAUSE WE WANTED TO PRESERVE
THE INTEGRITY OF THE ELECTION.
SO HERE YOU HAVE JUST ANOTHER
UNNAMED COMPUTER SCIENTIST
DEFENDING ELECTION INTEGRITY.
MAKE SENSE.
DON'T ASK QUESTIONS.
JAKE SULLIVAN DID NOT ASK
QUESTIONS.
HE TAKES SLATE.COM VERY
SERIOUSLY.
AT THE TIME JAKE SULLIVAN WAS
WORKING FOR THE HILLARY CLINTON
CAMPAIGN.
HE CITED THE SLATE STORY AS
EVIDENCE THAT TRUMP WAS
COLLUDING WITH PUTIN.
QUOTE, THE SECRET HOT LINE MAY
BE THE KEY TO UNLOCKING THE
MYSTERY OF TRUMP'S TIES TO
RUSSIA.
WE CAN ONLY ASSUME FEDERAL
AUTHORITIES WILL NOW EXPLORE
THIS DIRECT CONNECTION BETWEEN
TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
SO THERE WAS A BAT PHONE IN
TRUMP TOWER THAT RANK DIRECTLY
IN THE KREMLIN.
JAKE SULLIVAN STUCK TO THAT LINE
FOR ONCE.
HERE HE IS ON CNN IN MARCH OF
2017.
>> WHAT WE LEARNED DURING THE
CAMPAIGN WAS THAT VERY SERIOUS
COMPUTER SCIENCE EXPERTS, PEOPLE
WHO WORK CLOSELY WITH THE UNITED
STATES GOVERNMENT, HAD UNCOVERED
THIS SECRET HOT LINE BETWEEN THE
ALPHA BANK, THE RUSSIAN BANK,
AND THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION.
NOW, OF COURSE, WE DON'T KNOW
FOR SURE IF, IN FACT, THAT WERE
THE CASE, BUT WE KNEW THAT IT
SHOULD BE INVESTIGATED.
WE KNEW THAT GIVEN HOW SERIOUS
THESE COMPUTER SCIENTISTS WERE,
THEY WEREN'T JUST MAKING UP
CRACK POT THEORIES.
IT WASN'T SURPRISING TO LEARN
EVEN AS OF LAST WEEK THE FBI IS
STILL LOOKING INTO THIS.
>> DO YOU HAVE ANY IDEA WHAT
THEY'RE LOOKING FOR?
>> I DON'T.
I DON'T HAVE A LINE TO THE FBI
ON THIS, BUT WHAT I KNOW BASED
ON PUBLIC REPORTING IS THAT
THERE IS VERY UNUSUAL SERVER
ACTIVITY BETWEEN THIS RUSSIAN
BANK AND THE TRUMP ORGANIZATION
WHICH SUGGESTS CONTACT THAT TOOK
PLACE OVER THE COURSE OF THE
CAMPAIGN.
>> Tucker: OH, THE SECRET HOT
LINE.
THESE PEOPLE ARE LITERALLY
WILLING TO SAY ANYTHING IF IT
GIVES THEM POWER.
BUT LISTEN CAREFULLY WHAT JAKE
SULLIVAN SAID.
I DON'T HAVE A LINE INTO THE FBI
ON THIS.
EVERYTHING I KNOW IS FROM PUBLIC
REPORTING.
YOU KNOW HE WENT OUT OF HIS WAY
TO SAY THAT WHICH SHOULD HAVE
BEEN A VERY CLEAR SIGN TO SAY IT
WAS A LINE.
IT WAS A LIE.
THE FACT THE HILLARY CLINTON FOR
PRESIDENT CAMPAIGN WAS
COORDINATING WITH THEM.
THEY HAD BEEN SPREADING FALSE
CLAIMS ABOUT TRUMP AND RUSSIA.
FROM THAT CRACK POT OF COMPUTER
SCIENTISTS TO THE GENERAL
COUNCIL AT THE FBI, JAMES BAKER.
BUT HE DIDN'T STOP THERE.
IN FEBRUARY OF 2017 AFTER THE
ELECTION, SUSSMAN ALSO MET WITH
GENERAL COUNSEL AT THE CIA.
YOU MAY BE WONDERING ABOUT THE
IDENTITY OF THOSE NONPARTISAN
COMPUTER SCIENTISTS WHO DUG UP
ALL THIS INFORMATION ABOUT
DONALD TRUMP'S DIRECT CONNECTION
TO VLADAMIR PUTIN.
YOU MAY NOT BE SHOCKED TO LEARN
THEY WEREN'T NONPARTISAN.
ONCE AGAIN JAKE SULLIVAN WAS
LYING TO US.
IN FACT, A PRO HILLARY CLINTON
ACTIVIST FROM SOUTH AFRICA,
RODNEY SKWROF TPEU PUT TOGETHER
OPPO GUYS.
MOST CAME FROM GEORGIA TECH.
IN E-MAILS HE EXPLAINED WHY HE
WAS DOING IT.
HE WANTED HILLARY TO WIN THE
PRESIDENCY WAS HILLARY CLINTON
PROMISED HIM A JOB AS A TOP
CYBER SECURITY OFFICER IN THE
UNITED STATES GOVERNMENT.
JOFFEY WANTED TO HELP HILLARY
WIN.
IN ORDER TO DO THAT HE GAVE HIS
NONPARTISAN COMPUTER SCIENTISTS
A MISSION.
THEIR JOB WAS TO GATHER DATA
THEY HAD ACCESS TO THANKS TO A
GOVERNMENT CONTRACT TO CONNECT
TRUMP TO PUTTEN.
WE KNEW THAT BECAUSE OF JOHN
DURHAM WHO SPENT THE ORIGIN OF
THE RUSSIA HOGUES AND IS FINALLY
PRODUCING SOME MATERIAL.
IN THE WORDS OF THE FILING,
QUOTE, JOFFEY TASKED THOSE
RESEARCHERS TO MINE INTERNET DAY
TO TO ESTABLISH A NARRATIVE
TYING THEN CANDIDATE TRUMP TO
RUSSIA.
THIS WASN'T REPORTING, OF
COURSE.
THEY HAD A GOAL.
THEY WERE TRYING TO GET HILLARY
CLINTON ELECTED PRESIDENT.
THE AMAZING THING IS HOW THEY
DID IT WHERE THEIR DATA CAME
FROM.
THE FILING SAID JOFFEY AND HIS
SCIENTISTS INTERCEPTED INTERNET
TRAFFIC, E-MAILS, PRESUMABLY
TEXT MESSAGES FROM, QUOTE, TRUMP
TOWER, HIS CENTRAL WEST
APARTMENT BUILDING AND THE
EXECUTIVE OFFICE OF THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES.
IN OTHER WORDS, TRUMP WAS RIGHT.
THIS ISN'T A CONSPIRACY THEORY.
HIS CLAIMS WERE TRUE.
DEMOCRATS WERE SPYING ON DONALD
TRUMP, NOT JUST AS CANDIDATE,
BUT AS PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED
STATES IN THE WHITE HOUSE AS
WELL AS IN HIS OWN HOME.
SO HAS ANYTHING LIKE THIS
HAPPENED IN AMERICAN HISTORY?
NOT THAT WE KNOW OF.
BUT JEFF BEZOS DOESN'T THINK YOU
SHOULD KNOW ABOUT IT.
HE SAID WHILE TRUMP IS ONCE
AGAIN CLAIMING THAT HE WAS SPIED
UPON, THAT CLAIM HAS BEEN,
QUOTE, DEBUNKED.
OH REALLY?
HOW HAS IT BEEN DEBUNKED?
SHUT UP!
IT JUST HAS.
BUT, IN FACT, THAT CLAIM HAS NOT
BEEN DEBUNKED.
IT HAS BEEN VERIFIED.
THAT CLAIM IS TRUE.
IT ACTUALLY HAPPENED.
AND THE WAY IT HAPPENED TELLS
YOU EVERYTHING ABOUT WHY IT HAS
BEEN EXTRAORDINARILY DIFFICULT
TO BRING DEMOCRACY BACK TO THE
UNITED STATES.
A GOVERNMENT CONTRACTOR SPIED ON
A POPULOUS PRESIDENTIAL
CANDIDATE, THEN PASSED THE
INFORMATION TO HIS OPPONENT'S
CAMPAIGN, WHICH GAVE IT TO THE
FBI AND THE NEWS MEDIA WHICH
DISTORTED ITS ILLUSION OF TREATY
WHICH WAS CITED BY THE
POLITICIAN WHO PAID FOR THE
WHOLE THING AS A REASON NOT TO
VOTE FOR THE GUY SHE SPIED ON.
GOT IT?
A CLOSED LOOP.
EVERYONE'S GOT A ROLE.
HERE'S HILLARY CLINTON DURING
THE PRESIDENTIAL DEBATE.
>> FROM EVERYTHING I SEE, HAS NO
RESPECT FOR THIS PERSON.
>> WELL, THAT'S BECAUSE HE'D
RATHER HAVE A PUPPET AS
PRESIDENT.
>> NO PUPPET.
NO PUPPET.
YOU'RE THE PUPPET.
>> IT'S PRETTY CLEAR, YOU WON'T
ADMIT THAT THE RUSSIANS HAVE
ENGAGED IN CYBER ATTACKS AGAINST
THE UNITED STATES OF AMERICA
THAT YOU ENCOURAGED ESPIONAGE
AGAINST OUR PEOPLE, THAT YOU ARE
WILLING TO SPOUT THE PUTIN LINE,
SIGN UP FOR HIS WISH LIST, BREAK
UP NATO, DO WHATEVER HE WANTS TO
DO, AND THAT YOU CONTINUE TO GET
HELP FROM HIM BECAUSE HE HAS A
VERY CLEAR FAVORITE IN THIS
RACE.
>> Tucker: SO IF YOU'RE NOT ALL
IN WITH NATO, IF YOU THINK IT'S
DANGEROUS TO THE UNITED STATES
YOU, MY FRIEND, WORK FOR
VLADAMIR PUTIN.
YOU ENCOURAGED ESPIONAGE,
SHRIEKED HILLARY, JUST AS HE WAS
DOING THAT.
SHE WAS SPEAKING ABOUT A
SPECIFIC QUOTE CYBER ATTACK.
SHE WAS TALKING ABOUT THE
RUSSIANS HACKING THE SERVERS AT
THE DNC.
DEMOCRATS WASTED THREE YEARS OF
OUR LIVES TELLING US THAT IN
EVER INCREASING VOLUME.
HERE'S THE INTERESTING THING.
IT WAS NOT TRUE.
IT HAS NEVER BEEN TRUE.
VLADAMIR PUTIN DID NOT HACK THE
DNC.
THERE WAS NEVER ANY EVIDENCE
THAT THE RUSSIANS HACKED THE
DNC.
THEY WERE VERY CLEARLY STOLEN
FROM WITHIN THE BUILDING, MOST
LIKELY BY A BERNIE SANDERS
SUPPORTER.
THAT WAS VERY OBVIOUS TO ANYONE
WHO WAS PAYING ATTENTION AT THE
TIME.
WHAT'S INTERESTING IS THAT NO
ONE'S BEEN PUNISHED FOR IT.
LIKELY NO ONE EVER WILL BE.
JAKE SULLIVAN, THE GUY YOU JUST
SAW LYING ABOUT THOSE
NONPARTISAN COMPUTER SCIENTISTS,
HAS NOT BEEN INSRAOEUGTED FOR
WHAT HE DID.
JAKE SULLIVAN HAS BEEN PROMOTED.
JAKE SULLIVAN IS NOW PRESIDENT
BIDEN NATIONAL SECURITY ADVISER.
HE'S STILL SCREAMING ABOUT
RUSSIA.
ONLY THIS TIME IT'S NOT TO BRING
DOWN